so we've updated you on the NFL
situation the NBA looks like it's full
speed ahead by the end of July
hockey's coming back golf's coming back
everybody's coming back except for Major
League Baseball and of course that means
we have Tom Verducci on Tom
when is baseball coming back Dan I've
been thinking that all along and purely
of optimism because right now that
rhetoric is terrible both sides are
really dug in if you're just taking the
temperature of negotiations you would
say there's no agreement here but I
still believe Dan that the downside to
not playing baseball especially as you
mentioned all these other sports are up
and running is so enormous that's the
biggest motivator to get a deal done so
I'm still optimistic it doesn't look
like the fourth of July the way owners
originally wanted but I think somewhere
along the lines of 60 to 70 games maybe
beat by the beginning of August but the
NBA has the luxury of all being self
quarantined in Orlando you have your
basketball courts there you have the
facilities you'll have testing available
you know baseball is still we're not
quite sure are they gonna be in Arizona
and Florida Arizona or their home parks
here are you gonna play East Coast
versus ease code like there's a lot that
really has to be sorted out here and
then you have the money aspect here what
is front and center the biggest hurdle
before we have baseball it's the money
pure and simple I mean like you know one
of the little old-fashioned players
owners labor disputes and I think that's
with it why the downside is so big then
if there is no baseball it's not because
there was this an enormous concern about
the protocols and the health issues it's
strictly about money on the players side
I can tell you this the players now have
found a reason to be galvanized like I
have not seen in years this is not about
pensions or service time or some
esoteric CBA issue purely about taking a
pay cut they understand it they can
rally around it and I think that's why
they're dug in as far as where they play
you know listen I think they're a little
bit of benefit here as opposed to the
NBA they're playing the games outside
from what we know about the spread of
the virus it's a
less risky being outdoors where they
play it's looking it's looking like it's
going to be in major league ballparks
you know the state of Texas to say you
can have 50% capacity some places are
saying forget it you're not going to
count on anybody being in the ballpark
so it's it's a local issue in terms of
who is going to be there but they are
planning to play mostly empty ballparks
major league stadiums what will baseball
look like when it comes back um listen I
I'm like a lot of people I think I'll
take it any way I can get it
but when you think about the fact that
they're putting in 30 man rosters with
15 man pitching staffs after a three
week spring training I don't want to say
glorified spring training but the games
will be heavy in pitching changes and
less offense what's your two things we
don't want as fans right I mean we'll
have to take what we can get
but when baseball came back in 81
remember that was the two months strike
they started in August rosters remained
a 25 so baseball pretty much look the
same offense went slightly up in the
month of August of 81 but if you're
giving managers 15 man pitching staffs
and starting pitchers are not stretched
out to pitch even their usual 5 or 6
innings you're looking at more pitching
changes less offense just Jacob degrom
win the saw young with a 5 and 3 record
I guess it depends on his e ra right I
mean listen we're not gonna get a
quote-unquote legitimate season we're
not gonna get a quote-unquote legitimate
champion but if I can again go back to
81 you had four teams earned a playoff
spot remember that was a split season
year four teams got into the playoffs by
playing only 53 games there was a world
champion there you had a playoff system
alright it wasn't the usual 162 and
everything we're traditionally used to
but it still worked I mean I'll take it
and again it is there an asterisk you
know maybe at least mentally there is
but somebody's gonna win us a young
somebody's gonna be the MVP Baseball had
such a golden opportunity here like you
could have monopolized summer and and I
know that there's health issues but
really health is not first and foremost
here
I know Blake Snell said this this it's
always about money it's gonna be about
money if I gave baseball a do-over
through this time two months ago I give
the Commissioner and Tony Clark the head
of the Players Association to do over
what would you do over well I think you
start the negotiations from a closer
vantage point because remember owners
first came in and floated the idea of a
revenue sharing plan right a 50/50 split
well that's essentially a salary cap and
anybody's been around baseball for five
minutes never buy in the last 50 years
knows that that's a non-starter that was
not a good place to start and they came
back with this sliding pay cut thing
where Mike Trout Garrett called biggest
stars in the game but take the biggest
pay cuts well that's nothing to it with
the players because the union is a
top-down driven organization the players
are the ones up the stars of the game
who set the salary standards they have
the loudest voice even if it's a
minority of the rank-and-file so that
kind of ticked off the stars and their
agents especially the game so that kind
of got things off in a wrong spot there
Dan and I think we've lost time because
of that but you're absolutely right
there was an opportunity here I looked
at 4th of July weekend Cubs are playing
the Cardinals Yankees are playing the
Red Sox Dodgers are playing the Giants
we're starting to move about outdoors
baseball's got the advantage of being
sort of episodic right it's with us
every day
unlike the other sports are more event
oriented and being part of that
normalizing of routines in America
baseball would be a big part of that
Scott's still got a chance to do that
but it had the platform to itself by
being the first ones back now we don't
know I know we're optimistic we want to
be optimistic but how close are we to
the worst-case scenario here Tom that
there is no baseball this summer um you
know I don't know what the percentage is
Dan but it's a possibility and again I
think that to scare the pants off the
players and the owners because you're
talking about a sport the last seven
years attendance has declined every year
you cannot go 17 months without playing
a major league baseball game in this day
and age where baseball is that now the
last
shut down was 94 95 right that's a long
time ago that's a generation ago then
since then we have MMA we the NFL's
bigger the NBA's bigger there's so many
more entertainment opportunities for
people out there people are will be out
of the habit of baseball and don't
underestimate the power of habit you
know so I do think it's a possibility
but again I'm gonna still be on the side
of saying there's going to be a season
of some length I think somewhere around
70 and I say that because there's
actually some agreement here the players
say we want to be paid on a pro-rated
basis the owners came back and said okay
we'll do that but we'll only play 50
games so now actually philosophically
there is some agreement to me it's a
matter of finding what that number is
here that's palpable to the owners and
the players I'd like to think it's 70 I
know it's not that simple of just doing
math but at least philosophically they
can get to some schedule where players
are paid on a pro-rated basis which team
ER teams would benefit from a shortened
season this may surprise you
Tampa Bay Rays I look at that team and I
don't think there's any pitching staff
in baseball Dan that has better stuff
from 1 through 15 than the race and
again I think will expand a pitching
staff and pitchers going five innings
depth of quality arms is going to win
the day and I defy even the Dodgers I
don't think can match up 1 through 15 of
what the Rays can throw out there so I
think in a 50 to 70 game season the
Tampa Bay Rays the most dangerous team
this is all gonna be about pitching yep
yeah I think so and I think a lot of it
then too is how do you get these guys
ramped up in time to really hit the
ground running once games start you know
when I talked to Scott Boras about this
because she's got Gerrit Cole he's got
Stephen Strasburg
he's got Max Scherzer he actually
brought up the idea of just because
spring training 2.0 is three weeks why
would you put those elite pitchers at 30
million per year on that kind of
compressed schedule keep them on the
regular four or five weeks spring
training maybe they miss a starter to in
the quote-unquote regular season but
protect the
those elite arms maybe something that
teams have to look at so listen these
guys have kept their arms moving but
this has been like you know in a
purgatory State for three months for
these pictures you know they haven't
been really ramping up they haven't been
throwing off a mound they've been
playing catch
it's like January they never ends
preparing for a season so they'll come
back and varying degrees of shape in
terms of arm health and that's something
every club is gonna have to really
really pay attention to very closely I
can't imagine what your day is like no
matter where you go you probably get the
same question hey when's baseball coming
back like as if you're the gatekeeper
here and you decide when baseball's
coming back yeah but listen I understand
I kind of asked myself that question too
because there's a lot of frustration
down here because people want baseball
listen we all want all sports right we
want as much normalcy as we can but I
think people have figured out here that
the reason there is no plan for baseball
right now is simply money and maybe
that's unfair to boil it down that way
but baseball I think has to be aware
that if there is no baseball as I said
people are not just out of the habit of
baseball they will resent baseball man
because it will be because we didn't
have gauge it was only because they
couldn't agree about money yeah I think
that's a really good point and we'll
wind it there Tom great to talk to you
again get baseball back okay come on
thank you Tom Tom Verducci Sports
Illustrated senior baseball writer and
MLB Network analyst